Valon knocks down the three New York's
lead swelling to 25 points Perkins
missed the big boy move inside and we're
gonna take a bow she booted him she ran
him Nick you played it Buffalo you're
getting a chance here don't get tossed
and Natalie say go the official looks
like she is showing him the door she
must have said one of the real bad works
all right hit him on the head to fire oh
yeah oh he threw his headband at him
he's got to be gone ripped off his
headband and threw it out stole his head
empty see all the Select come off that
Nick you gotta go man
like he's
pounding they give you ten fouls in
summer league but you can't rip a guy's
headband off and throw it at him here's
one more look she just went out and he
has been ejected from the game
snicker khun's that's allowed to go home
but you got to get up out of here I'd be
a bad coach perfect like miles did the
right thing you know gay man [ __ ] I
think that started at the other end he
was frustrated a lot somebody needs to
tell Nick Perkins how dumb that is for
Nick Perkins not for anybody else you're
trying to make a team
yeah
so Natalie sable coming over and
explaining to us that